welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Jennifer van vleck an assistant
professor of history and American
Studies at Yale
she's an historian of 20th century US
and international history her research
and teaching focus on u.s. foreign
relations with particular emphasis on
the ways in which culture technology and
private enterprise have shaped the
United States role in the world
she is also interested in transnational
approaches to the study of Empire and
imperialism modernization and
globalization today we'll talk with
Professor Van Vleck about her new book
Empire of the air aviation and the
American ascendancy for which she was
awarded the Macmillan Center's Gatiss
Smith International Book Prize for best
first book
welcome professor van Black Thank You
Marilyn I'm pleased to be here so let's
start with an overview of your book tell
us about it
so my book uses aviation as a lens on to
the United States rise as a global power
in the 20th century from the Wright
brothers first flights in 1903 through
the jet age and the book focuses
primarily on commercial aviation but
military airpower is also a significant
part of the story is as I can explain a
little bit more later and so the book is
really really kind of has two kind of
parallel stories or interconnected
stories I should say one is the
diplomatic history of aviation and the
role of the airplane in u.s. foreign
relations particularly in terms of the
expansion of American commercial power
and then the other story is about the
cultural history of aviation and the
ways in which ideas about aviation
inspired Americans to imagine the world
and the United escalate the United
States place within it in new ways and
today when flying is basically like
riding an airborne Greyhound bus it's
kind of hard to imagine a time in which
aviation captivated the public
imagination in the way that it did in
the mid 20th century but in the period
of time that I look at so be
secondly the early 1900s through the
1970s aviation really had kind of
transcendent significance and especially
because this was an era in which flying
was very expensive it was considered a
luxury and how to you know kind of
connotations of glamour and people were
fascinated by it so even though only a
small minority of people could actually
afford to fly discourse of and images of
aviation pervaded American culture in
advertisements in film in newspapers and
magazines and so my book really examines
kind of the cultural history of aviation
as a way of understanding how Americans
came to terms with and kind of
legitimized the United States expanding
global power so beyond the story about
aviation that's really a story about the
United States rise as a global power in
a particular kind of global power okay
and what led you to write the book so I
should say it was not a direct flight
whose a rather circuitous route so so as
you said in your introduction my primary
research interest concern culture
business and technology in the history
of u.s. foreign relations and so when I
was in graduate school I I had to write
a seminar paper for this course called
the American century which was taught by
my advisor John Christophe Agnew and
right before in the process of choosing
my seminar paper topic I happened to see
the movie catch me if you can and it's a
cultural historian I was really
fascinated by the kind of the
iconography of air travels depicted in
that movie and has been depicted in
subsequent TV shows such as Mad Men for
example and ABC's now cancelled series
Pan Am
so I started become to become very
interested in the history of Pan Am you
know first of all why did this one
airline have such an incredible cultural
alluring this period of time but then I
was also curious about why Pan Am was
called Pan Am because that name implies
some kind of connection to Pan
Americanism which in turn implies a
connection to the history of u.s. Latin
American relations which was also a
topic that I was interested in exploring
so I wrote this paper and I found out
that
the indeed Pan Am first expanded its
routes throughout Latin America in the
1920s and 1930s and had a very complex
and interesting relationship to u.s.
foreign policy in that region so from
there I started to think about the
relationship between aviation and u.s.
foreign policy more broadly and I
realized that even though there's a
massive popular literature on aviation
history at that point in time at least
aviation was really kind of marked
marginalized in historical scholarship
it was it was considered a subject that
was of interest to buffs not serious
academic historians so I really wrote
this book with the intention of changing
that with you know with the intention of
emphasizing that looking at aviation
really can help us develop new
perspectives on big questions in
international history and American
history so that leads me to the research
itself how how did you do the research
what was your methodology so there are
three main bodies of sources the first
was government documents primarily State
Department documents but I also did a
lot of research and presidential
libraries to basically understand the
kind of the foreign policy side of the
story the second group of sources were
cultural sources so advertisements films
novels newspapers and magazines from the
United States and other countries and
again this was a way of understanding
how people were talking about aviation
and it was like the fun part of the it
was definitely the fun part especially
working with the advertisements because
the imagery is just so rich now I was
lucky to have access to at Duke
University they have a very large
collection of advertisements and records
from the J Walter Thompson the
advertising agency which was one of the
most influential agencies in the US and
they did advertising and publicity for a
lot of major airlines so that was a
really wonderful archive to use and then
finally my third body of sources were
the records of Pan American World
Airways or Pan Am which is really kind
of the main protagonist of my book and
it's usually very difficult to get
access to corporate records but
fortunately after Pan Am went out of
business in the late 19th early 1990s
they donated their records to the
University of Miami so
was able to go and look at those and of
course Miami was was a very nice place
to do research especially in the winter
huh okay so let's talk about some
examples of how the commercial aviation
during this time period helped the
United States rise in terms of
globalization so - in two main ways
one aviation literally expanded and
strengthened the kind of the material
backbone of American power in the world
both militarily and economically the
United States worldwide infrastructure
of air routes and air bases facilitated
global commerce obviously it enabled new
and more powerful methods of warfare and
it it literally allowed the United
States to have a larger kind of global
footprint in many nations Pan Am
especially in the 1920s and 30s Pan Am's
sales offices served as kind of informal
embassies and then on the other hand
aviation as I said also really changed
the ways that Americans thought about
their nations role in the world and
especially because the kind of the
visual the visual iconography that
aviation inspired allowed people to
think about the world as one there's a
kind of unified global space so so
images of air routes for example allowed
people to kind of picture the world is
interconnected first of all and also the
world as kind of a single object of
influence for the United States so it
suggested that American power could go
everywhere it suggested that there were
no limits to that but and this is a one
of the crucial arguments of the book is
that even in kind of expressing this
kind of new expansionist imaginary the
discourse surrounding aviation basically
denied that the American expansion had
to had anything to do with traditional
forms of empire so the idea was that
whereas European empires were
territorial and involved conquering land
and ruling over populations the United
States would have an empire of the air
which would be based on
gets in access to commerce and in my
book I argue that that in many ways was
a fiction because airplanes obviously
need airports they need massive
resources and tracts of land in the
United States had had a very large
territorial footprint in the world but
still it was a different kind of empire
so it helped to aviation help to
reconcile Americans traditional
anti-imperialist sensibilities with
their nation's growing global power
so Pan Am was the first airline
basically so first in u.s. international
era yes so and they basically were flown
flying to South America Latin America
countries and is that because the
president was a latin american no so
here's the interesting thing about the
Pan Am that most people don't know so
most people when they think of Pan Am
they think about the president want rip
who is this kind of larger-than-life
very colorful character and despite his
his Hispanic first name he was a wasp
through and through he was actually grew
up he was the son of a banker grew up on
New York's Upper East Side he was named
after one of their families and an aunt
but only by marriage so he had no
connections to Latin America but so but
he also did not found PanAm and this is
this is what most people don't know the
airline was actually founded by a trio
of military officers in 1927 and they
were concerned about the security of the
Panama Canal because this was a time in
which a number of airlines in South
America had German and Austrian backing
and they were worried that these
airlines would could potentially
jeopardize the security of the Penn the
Panama Canal so they wanted to have a
u.s. airline in the region - first of
all protect the canal but then also to
uphold the Monroe Doctrine that the
United States is supposed to be the
dominant commercial power in the region
and and it's closed to further European
influence okay so in addition to the so
back in the 50s the first consumer
flight I'll call it a consumers like
we're average people although probably
upper-class average people we're taking
these flights so they were going
predominantly where in the world so I'll
back up and say
another reason why Panem started in
Latin America was that airplanes didn't
have the technology for transoceanic yes
exactly
so the earliest flights were actually
from Miami to Havana Cuba and it was
called the cocktail circuit because this
of course in the late 1920s was
prohibition and the people were flying
to to Cuba basically to party right but
but by the end of World War two of
course airplanes to develop the
technological capacity to fly worldwide
so by the mid 1950s especially with
things like the introduction of tourist
fairs which did make flying more
affordable Americans were really flying
everywhere I mean of course you know the
transatlantic market was was the most
competitive and most traveled market but
aviation did a lot to to basically
create kind of new new tourist
destinations especially in the
post-colonial and the developing world
and Panem in particular was instrumental
to that because in addition to in
addition to the airline the company
owned the Intercontinental Hotel chain
which kind of specialized in creating
kind of modern American style luxury
hotels you know in places like you know
places like Africa and you know places
that didn't already have that kind of
tourist infrastructure Wow
very interesting so what was enduring
the research what was something that
perhaps was most surprising to you that
you didn't expect
two things I mean I think certainly the
extent of the extent of military
airpower in the history of commercial
aviation I mean I knew obviously there's
connection especially on the level of
funding in the ways that technologies
develop but I certainly didn't expect to
find that Panem itself had been falen
founded by military officers with an
explicitly military purpose or one that
aligned with with Kimes military
strategy and so when I began the project
I very much thought that it was going to
be about commercial aviation because air
power has a very large literature of its
own but but I realized that the two the
two histories are really deeply
intertwined and then the other thing
which is a kind of funny I
I didn't expect that airline passengers
in the 1940s and 50s complained about
air travel just as much as we do today
for somewhat different reasons but
especially in the immediate post-war
period the nations kind of airport
infrastructure just could not handle the
volume of passengers at the time so you
know so things were happening like you
know planes were you know we're having
to circle airports you know for up to an
hour before they could land and you know
and there are all kinds of articles and
magazines like Harper's and time and
life year like why is flying so
miserable and it's just it's it's funny
because we know yeah because we now
remember that period kind of nostalgic
Lee is this golden age of air traveling
and in many ways it certainly was more
luxurious in terms of you know basic
things like you know you were served a
real meal and a martini and things like
that but the especially the physical
experience of flying was was not was not
as wonderful as we often think it it was
today interesting so Pan Am ended up
going under in the early 1990s do you
think it was because it was originally
founded on the military aspects of you
know air travel a VA ssin do you think
they you know missed the boat along the
way in terms of the commercialization of
air travel I think the real issue has to
do with the changing relationship
between the airline industry in the
state so basically until 1978 when
President Carter deregulated the
aviation industry Airlines depended
heavily upon government subsidies to
operate and so the kind of the so-called
legacy airlines the airlines like Pan Am
and TWA that had routes all over the
world they were never really financially
sustainable without those kinds of
subsidies so after the airline
deregulation Act they couldn't really
compete with these new low-cost carriers
many of which operated with non-union
labor and so I think I suppose that you
could make some arguments about kind of
the ways in which commercial aviation
started to have kind of less strategic
significance but I think it really has
to do more with with regulation and
deregulation and
those kinds of changes okay all right
and so what do you conclude in your book
so I conclude first of all that aviation
is a really important element of the
story of u.s. foreign relations that the
one that is that is often I think
unfortunately overlooked I agree you
know I when you when you think about how
important the air travel and bringing
people to places that they have never
been before I agree it's um I think it
has been missed
mm-hmm yeah I think that especially
because it was so culturally popular and
and it had this kind of you know rich
cultural iconography and discourses
surrounding and I think it's a really
the history of aviation is a really good
way to understand how Americans have
envisioned the world and that that's
essentially what the book is about it's
really it's a history of the American
global imaginary and the reason why I
wanted to examine this is that around
the time that that I began working on
the project a lot of historians were
pursuing transnational projects that you
know rather than looking at the history
of a single nation as historians have
traditionally been trained to do there's
a lot of new interest in scholarship
that not only looked at relations
between nations but aim to understand
the nation-state itself in historical
terms and yet I saw in a lot of that
work there was often the kind of
reflexive tendency to throw around terms
like trans national or global without
really unpacking the ways in which those
terms came to signify with what they do
so what I wanted to to argue is that the
the term the global the very ways that
we imagine the world those are
historically constructed just as the
nation itself is the product of history
so too is the conception of the global
that has driven American expansion in
the 20th century so I wanted to trace
the kind of the origins and the meanings
of that concept fascinating thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work thank you very
much I appreciate it
for more information about Professor Van
Vleck and her research please visit our
website at Yale edu slash McMillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the McMillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you